so in ja was a or Revelation from God
revealed to Jesus Christ of Nazareth he
preached it he taught it to Israel he
preached it and he taught it to Israel
all right all right you know because at
that time because we don't believe in
the eyewitnesses I'm tell you from my
perspective we don't believe in the
eyewitnesses rather we believe a oral
transmission that's why the Bible has
like I'm not going against the Bible but
I'm just saying like why we believe has
some
contradictions that is fair enough
that's all right but yeah it was an oral
Revelation okay not it wasn't it wasn't
like
written you don't you don't believe you
don't believe the was written no it was
all
Revelation okay do you have your kurran
on you yeah all right turn to chapter 7
verse 157 really
quick seems like we got a pretty good
respectful guest to start us off today
guys which is which is always awesome
it's always awesome someone said Diddy
over theet the unlettered
message the unlettered
prophet whose descriptions they find in
the gospel who description they find in
the Tor and gospel yeah now specifically
that word description in the Arabic
that's all you have to read that that's
it but the word for their their in
description actually it's not
description it's written
um the word in the Arabic is
Makin Makin which means written so it
says that they will find the unlettered
prophet um in the Torah and the gospel
or the
inil written with
them oh I lost what
happened did I lose
him did I did I did I lose
him did I did
I did I lose him
oh what is it
man why is it that I can't keep the
respectful calm guests
why only the real ones know what I was
referencing right
there oh man okay
well let's try uh let's try someone
else someone said don't cry
H what's up man how you
doing wow don't nobody want to stay
yo greetings hey what's up you
Muslim yes welcome to the stage you're
you're a Muslim named Billy
huh yes
sir okay how long youve been a
Muslim uh I was born second generation
Muslim born second generation Muslim so
what does that mean that your parents
were Muslim and then you're Muslim gr
yeah my mother was okay okay okay okay
cool cool cool so tell us what's the
ngel my
friend theel was what was revealed to
Issa okay at least there okay what was
that specifically
though it was a
revelation scripture that was given to
him yeah like what like what's what was
that scripture that's what I'm that's
what I'm asking
basically what what's the scripture um
it was the law you know that was given
TOA for the children of Israel do you
believe that I have the NG
today no no no I don't right so you have
it okay so how do how do you know so
when you say that I don't that I don't
have it that means that you have that
you know something specific of what it
is you know what the ngil is since you
know that I don't have it so that's why
I'm asking so what is it then since I
don't have it what is
it I mean it was it was what was
revealed to ISA you know over 2000 years
ago okay how do you know you have it do
you claim to have it well let's let's
work with it I I I am claiming to have
it I'm I'm claiming that I have the NGO
you're saying that I don't so that's
what I'm saying how do you know I don't
have it what makes you well what makes
you know that you do have it that's
that's you switching it unto me now I I
I'll break it down actually matter of
fact I'll break it down so um can we
agree that the NGO was
written um I I can't I don't know that
for sure I just know that given to fair
enough that's that's a that's a humble
answer I could respect that so look this
is what the Quran says in chapter 7
verse 1057 it says those who follow the
unlettered prophet whom whom they
find written with them in the Torah and
the
inil all right so it mentions how
Muhammad's prophecies right Prophecies
of Muhammad coming are written in the
Torah and the injil so by this verse we
know from the Quran that the injil was
written do you believe that verse to be
true of course
not oh okay
but so how do you know you
have oh well about we're about to we're
working through it so these this in Jill
is something that Jesus went around
preaching right this is a revelation
that Jesus went around preaching and
then eventually it got written down
somehow by someone do you know that
that's what the Quran says so are you
using the Quran to prove your yes
claim okay all right so so the Quran
can you repeat the verse again chapter
7 verse 157 it says those who follow the
unlettered prophet whom they find
written with them in the Torah and the
injil so that ayat was revealed to
Prophet Muhammad
Alam that yeah this is Muhammad what
Muhammad's saying well it was it was
revealed to him
that the unlettered pro was written in
the Torah in the and who was he who was
who was that being spoken to like who
was
that that verse was revealed for a
reason I'm sure you're familiar with the
T here uh yes it's the reason is to
prove to the Jews and the Christians
that Muhammad is in their scriptures and
so they should believe in him as well
they shouldn't reject him the Jews and
Christians at what at what time the time
of Prophet Muhammad in the time of yes
in Muhammad's
time so the Jews and Christians had a
Torah in inia yep during Muhammad's
time did they call it the Torah in in
jail like you claim to have the in jail
yeah they call it the
gospel and the Torah so if it was you
know meant for the Jews and the
Christians to look with what they claim
to have had what else would they have
been looking into that's the question
that right there and what and so my
point is I tell you looking uhhuh I I'll
I'll open up the Gospel Matthew Mark
Luke and John the New
Testament so okay so let's so let's
let's let's continue let's continue the
line of thought Billy so we know that we
know that the gospel is with the
Christians and in the seventh century
and is written down they have a written
form of the Gospel that let's clar let's
clarify let's clarify clarify I thought
we we know that no no we know that what
the Christians claim to have had like
you claim to have had have right now is
what they call the
in okay so we know that what the
Christians claim to have had during the
time of the Prophet
Muhammad they called what they had the
sorry actually this is what the Quran is
saying that they have the Quran is
claiming that the Christians have the
inel the gospel I mean the Quran is
speak it to the Jews and Christians to
look you know to what they have had what
they have yes so so to speed this up
they
call to speed this up to speed this up
so we know from the Quran that the
Christians had the gospel in their
possession
correct from what they know for what
they called they had the gospel no not
not what they call let me let me let me
ask it again just I want you to hear me
clearly let me give you an example no no
no hear me clearly so that we can move
forward because it s it kind of sounds
like you're stalling so let's move
forward in the conversation according to
the Quran the Quran says that they have
a written injil with them the written
gospel with them
right yes okay so let's move forward so
they have the gospel it's written and
they have it it has Muhammad's
prophecies in there let's move forward
so now in the seventh century they have
a written
gospel who wrote
it who wrote the Gospel
yes I I don't know what you know the
gospel that they had with them that the
Quran claims that they have because what
they had they called The Gospel I don't
know who wrote it got it you know just
like you don't know who wrote your
gospel well I do I I we we claim that
Matthew Mark Luke and John since it has
their names on the manuscripts Matthew
Mark Luke and John are the ones who
wrote down the gospels so with that
being said if you're saying how my
question since you don't know who wrote
the Gospel who wrote the
Ino how do you know Christian head at
time mam yeah how do you know that
Matthew Mark Luke and John didn't write
[Music]
that uh don't I don't I don't know that
what they had at the time in the seventh
century they had a mark Matthew Mark and
E zone right so you don't got you so you
so you don't know who wrote it you don't
know if Matthew Mark Lan John are the
ones who wrote it I'm gonna wait till
you come back so that uh are you can you
hear me yeah yeah yeah I'm so you don't
know who wrote it you don't know if
Matthew Mark Luke and John are the ones
who wrote it so therefore you can't tell
me that I don't have the
Ino um The Gospel of Jesus written by
Matthew Mark Luke John you can't say
that I don't have it when you don't know
what it is and you don't know who wrote
it in the first place you get what I'm
saying I I know that it was revealed to
Esau Jesus peace and bless be upon him
you don't know that marthew M Mark and
John wrote that okay so so scholar don't
know that so so here we are here we are
um
when you say that you don't know who
wrote the Gospel who do you think would
have written
it it's not it's not really for me to
think I just know that it is just give
an educated guess give an educated guess
we know we know it was revealed we got
past that it was revealed Jesus preached
it orally we also know that it was
written down who do you think would have
written
it I don't I don't know I'm not claiming
to know I know you're not I know you're
not claiming to know who do you think
think would have written down the
teachings of Jesus as Jesus is going
around preaching and teaching who do you
think would have scribed down his his
what he's saying and preaching and doing
I mean it's irrelevant honestly but very
relevant how is it relevant go ahead go
ahead you was about to say go ahead I'll
show you how I me his
disciples or his scribal people yeah his
disciples His companion very good I
agree with you I agree so we both agree
that the gospel would have been written
by Jesus's
disciples and so we have that we have
Matthew was a disciple of Jesus we have
John that was a disciple of Jesus
because it's in the go Matthew because
it's in the gospel what's Abu herrera's
last
name I mean I I could find it easily who
Abu Hur was yeah yeah show show me show
me Abu H's last
now that's the you know that's the
difference between yeah good if it's if
it's a difference sure good show me Abu
herrera's last name so I show you abu's
last name his his lineage and all of
that what is that gonna do for you
exactly that exactly absolutely nothing
if you get me if you get me Abu
herrera's first and last name if you get
me his lineage hold on hold on a second
if you get me his first and last name
you give me his lineage it does nothing
for me it doesn't the it doesn't change
the fact that he's narrating stuff well
I would not even just get his last name
I would get you about his character I
get you his family about how he lived
Billy are you are you listening to are
you listening to what's going
on listen Okay so pay attention pay
close
attention you telling me the lineage of
Abu Hera doesn't doesn't negate does I
don't hey Billy respectfully man if you
can't engage with what we're talking
about I'm G just have to go on to the
next guest honestly man because this is
this is getting like really slow this is
really slow okay then engage please so I
don't care who Abu herrera's mom or dad
was who what his last name is that
doesn't change whether whether what he
reported is true or false we can know
nothing about Abu H Herrera but that
doesn't change whether what he said and
reported about Muhammad is true or false
what matters is what he said and does it
cor correlate with history and facts
that's what matters okay so Matthew I
don't need to tell you who Matthew's mom
was or his last name I don't got to tell
you none of that all I got to do is show
you Matthew and show you that he
historically was a disciple of Jesus
which we have his names listed as one of
the 12 not just in the gospel but also
by the people who followed the disciples
after and carried the traditions we have
this stuff that's all you that's all
need Matthew and by by the way you don't
know who his disciples were so you can't
tell me who or who isn't a disciple you
can't tell me that I don't have the
gospel that Matthew wrote that Mark
wrote dictated by Peter that John wrote
that Luke wrote at the dictation of the
eyewitnesses you can't tell me that they
didn't write it that they weren't the
disciples who wrote it you can't tell me
because you don't know you get what I'm
saying all right yeah I I think you got
a little
you know you went a little left and got
stuck on the last name part you know it
wasn't really to identify whether his
last name you know signified if it was
true or not um to be a little bit more
specific you know we just don't know his
last name his L we know his character
you know we know his mentality we know
his memory we know you know what he did
and how the
effort that has nothing to do with
anything that has nothing to do with the
point that I'm asking you about if you
don't if you don't let me let me tell
you why if you don't
know who wrote the
gospels how can you tell me that Matthew
Mark Luke and John did not write the
NG I'm telling you because nobody knows
who they are outside of
the own their own
alleged scriptures oh so people do know
who they are because we have details
about them in the scriptures interesting
who outside of the scriptures like who
who knows them nobody knows so outside
outside of outside outside of the Hadith
who knows abua outside of the Hadith who
knows Usman out of outside of the Hadith
who knows Abu
Bakr there the scholars there's a chain
of oh so if we have if we have Scholars
where are they getting it from you don't
have Scholars where your where are your
Scholars getting their information about
Abu Bakr about uh uh Abu hrera where are
they getting their information about him
about these characters where they where
are they going what was from from what
was preserved which in what through that
was that was remain in preservation in
what and the
Quran so outside of your scriptures what
wait hold on a second Billy outside of
your outside of your scriptures there's
no information about these characters
that you trust and love and Revere but
these Scholars they get their
information about these people from the
scriptures you believe in interesting so
it's cool when you do it but it's a
problem when we do it is that it no no
no a major difference there's a major
difference the sources that you know
that cross reference each companion
scholar and other than that is thanks
for coming a million times more than was
in the thanks for coming